Never have I ever, but
never have I ever had a threesome? Wow.
Hi everyone. My name is June. I am an actor MC comedian on Instagram,
and I make a lot of short form comedy skits.
One thing I do genuinely love to do is pair people up. I love playing matchmaker
called love lap,
where I bring on two contestants and make them spend 24 hours together on a
virtual game. You heard me correctly, 24 hours together.
Could I have possibly tapped into something 24 hours?
Beat the perfect concussions to the finding the love of your life. We'll see.
All right, what's your name?
I adjourn. I'm drew. Hi,
I'm drew I'm 24 now. Jesus.
I'm an animator. This has got a geeky, but I have like a Google doc set up.
It should be like, okay, if we run out of activities,
but Tensley stuff we could do kind of romantic.
I like that for what I'm looking for in a partner. Ideally,
it'd be nice to have someone else. Who's also nerdy, geeky as I am.
Definitely someone who's ambitious. Hi. Hi. Nice to meet you.
Hi, my name is Jordan Chan. I'm 21 years old and I am currently unemployed.
Thanks to coronavirus. What I'm looking for in a partner in a romantic context,
I guess would be somebody who has a good sense of humor.
Somebody who's spontaneous and somebody who's sincere. How was your banter game?
Oh, please.
Just hold off.
I really love getting to know new people. So I'm really excited,
but obviously I'm rather nervous as well, but that's just like it.
That's inevitable.
First. I'll bring in. True next. We'll bring in Jordan. Well,
Jordan, this is true. True. This is Jordan. Say hello.
Hi.
You guys are going to go there.
Without further ado. I'm going to let you guys go.
And your 24 hour starts now.
Oh my God. Jordan.
Nice to meet you too.
Nervous all the way up to this. Like I was talking to Judy about it,
but like I couldn't sleep last night.
Obviously. We're going to get to know each other fairly well.
Every 24 hours is a very long time.
It's going to be a lot of awkward silence.
It's okay. You know, we'll just roll through it. Like it's all good.
Yeah.
There's the first moment of silence.
Hey guy. Sweet. Are you all getting hungry?
I think it's time to share a first meal show your table that you have in your
fridge. I'm going to eat on my front lawn. We're going to have a virtual picnic.
I'm feeling.
I feel like a weird cooking show. Now.
Pretend you're on a cooking show. Go.
So I take these and then put in so normal
this Crick stuff,
but then a little bit of cinnamon and some almond milk and then put in half a
scoop away for it.
So healthy master chef over here.
Sure. Cheers to her virtual picnic.
I'm going to go for a coffee and there's this couple who's like on a date and
they're simply so hard right now. They're both like holding hands. Like
how do you feel about PDA?
I'm normally not like a gushy person in general.
I mean, like I like romcoms and romcoms. I can stand in your life.
It's different. I don't know. There's a certain amount of cheese, but like, yes.
Have I hit any of your red flags?
Uh, not yet. Hey Jordan,
how are you?
Okay. How are you? I've been.
Anxiously waiting. Um, how was lunch?
It was good. I had, we had a picnic.
First impressions.
I mean, he's, he's cool.
He's he's he seems like a really chill dude, but I,
I don't know if like we're compatible on a romantic level.
I feel like she's just as open and honest and upfront.
Like we both can easily talk about, uh, I guess anything with our lives.
I don't know. He seems really easy to talk to.
He seems really relaxed and he's really, I don't know.
I like talking to him. He's like, he seems like a really good guy.
I think she's probably a little out of my league, but uh,
I think it's really cool. Jabu
how into fashion. Oh, I'm very into perfect.
So I was thinking we could give each other like themes of like a fashion
outfit or something and you can be like, what's your favorite outfit?
Oh, cute. That's so cute. So cute.
Let's do something really loud. Okay. Ooh,
you look like you're going to the club kind of same vibe kind of say,
Ooh, Oh my God. Ooh.
I love that this shoes are phenomenal. I do the wave a lot.
You go to a club and everyone's grinding and he's like grinding.
So pouring like, okay, like, sure. Like it's stimulating whatever sex,
but like I want to do like cringey spins and escape. You know,
like you have to give me yours.
Your Instagram feed really reminds me of my ex.
That's good. That was the impression I'm wanting to go.
Professional glitter sheets.
No telling me that this isn't professional.
I think you're really sweet. I don't know. You seem like.
A very kind person.
[Inaudible] yeah. You're Cynthia.
Um, I'll, I'll go with the very simple response, but um,
I think you're really pretty. I think it's pretty dope, I guess.
Hey guys, it's me June. It's five o'clock somewhere.
Oh, are y'all down for a happy hour? Drink up. Hell yeah. I'm going to.
Give you the choice of what I'm going to be drinking.
Tonight. Tequila jurors, chairs, clink.
Never have I ever gone to work high ever.
Never have I ever had a threesome? Wow.
I'm a little tipsy. So I'm not sure. I think it's approaching hour seven.
The more I talked to him, the more I like. Yeah, it's cool.
I feel like we're really getting to know each other on a deeper level.
Of course won't be like a fourth of the way through this 24 hour date.
So I think you should give me a list of,
of three possible friends or you'd need just give me one friend and I'm going to
call that friend, put myself on mute. Ask them to describe you too.
Awesome. Okay.
Hi Maria. This is uh, drew. This is the random dude that,
uh, Jordan just told you about.
I figured I give you the chance just to tell me about Jordan.
He's just nodding.
Cool. Uh, thanks Mario. I appreciate you taking this random call.
I want you to tell me why he would be a good person to date and also why
he would not be a good person to date
a good person today. He's extremely loyal
in terms of like his bad side, the
green money. Uh, pretty funny, kind of funny.
Okay. Thank you, Amber. It was nice chatting with you. That was interesting.
That was fun. And also nerve wracking. Hi,
what's your name?
I'm Jordan. Jordan to meet you guys.
Okay. I dare you to do your makeup or have your, Oh my God.
Have your girl room. I do your makeup.
Can I give you some inspo? I only have Island,
but go for it. Oh, you don't have any eye shadow or lipstick. Uh,
I might have some lip gloss,
maybe pop that sucker out.
And this is the finished look. Amazing. Incredible.
And I want you to put on some makeup,
like raccoon eyes. I told you I will do any hair.
This is so fad.
He doesn't have fragile masculinity, which is like,
yeah, he's not afraid to, you know, look like a fool and goof off.
We've mashed up a little bit with our sense of humor, which is nice.
And you can actually banter back and forth, which I think is important.
I think I'm pretty compatible. We'll see how she feels.
Okay. Making PV and J Hey, Skippy's Skippy.
Cheers.
A romantic dinner. So we got to have a candle if there's a romantic dinner.
Well, all right,
I'm going to let some candles to who or what might have stopped you from
realizing your full potential. Oh. We're going deep.
We're always our own worst enemies. We're we're always our worst critics.
So I feel like the person who holds me back the most is me.
Is there a specific moment where you feel like you held yourself back?
There've been myriad times in my life where I've not taken advantage of
opportunities presented for me because I'm like, Oh,
you're not good enough to do that. Anyway. Might as well, not even try,
you know, what about you?
This is like, it's kind of oddly specific,
but it's like a moment in sixth grade where I kind of began more focusing within
myself and not being as social.
So I feel like if I had a little more of that time to be able to
socialize and learn,
it would have helped a lot later years where I wasn't as socially developed or
was more socially awkward and had to learn when everyone else had already
figured out social cues and all that kind of stuff.
How are you feeling?
I mean,
I'm honestly pleasantly surprised because I really thought there would be more
awkwardness, but it's maybe really the organic conversation.
So you guys drink a little bit tipsy at all? Yeah. I got drunk.
You got drunk. Okay. Did it go up a few points? Well, yeah.
You know what? The more I talked to him, the more I liked him, he seems like,
you know, from our previous talk, you've loosened up a little bit.
Are you saying I was uptight before? No. Come up,
give him a little bit of a chance. Give him a little bit, a little bit.
And it seems like, it seems like you have, so I'm just,
I was open-minded you find yourself a little more attracted to her just as a
person or romantically? Yeah.
I mean, I, I think from the get go,
I said in my diary that I think she's sadly pretty.
Much a gentleman.
And uh, honestly a little out of my league, but wow.
We'll just go and let that show, man. It was my pitch.
Every time we laugh, we have to drink. Okay. Ready?
Three, two, one.
I know all the lyrics.
We're about to do a virtual room door, the door, the towel,
because I'm loud. My mirror, my bucket hats,
my keyboard, my raisin bran, my knitting supplies.
My vinyl records, my photo albums, my book.
Yeah.
My door VR had set first closet all filled with
all of my crazy button ups that I have. This, uh,
is definitely a deal breaker for a lot of people.
This is my pet I've had since I was six and
he's grown up with me. So he's definitely kind of an essential,
this is my snake. Oh my God.
I totally forgot. He had a snake.
So how do you feel about snakes? I guess.
I mean, I don't like the,
I don't have an opinion on them.
Like they're cool, but yeah, I'm not crazy.
Can you take your snake out? Do you want me to?
You're an interesting fellow.
Oh my God.
Oh my God. That's so weird. Our.
Yeah, this dude's pretty normal hour 13. Did I get.
I I'm going to admit it. I'm a very difficult person to date.
So I have major clinical depression.
And so I know that's obviously a difficult thing to tackle when you're
dating somebody. So usually when I have depressive episodes,
I tend to retreat. I don't like asking other people for help.
Unfortunately, I'm exactly the same way. I mean, obviously I don't,
I can't to on clinical depression,
I think I have mild depression definitely have anxiety, but uh,
when I have a problem or issue, I get really dark.
I like get off the grid and like completely want to handle it by myself.
And it's like, I don't want anyone else trying to come from me to talk to me.
Each other or a picture that you think represents you,
your eyeliner, your mascara and your spiky hair.
This is you writing your pet lizard into war.
It took you that long to draw. Shut up. I told you I'm bad at drawing.
There was one day I was really craving.
I didn't have anything to eat the Manny's with. So I ate to me
what a combination. How did it taste? First of all,
as we went on,
I was able to back pedal away from that and tear down the wall a little more.
I don't really see the purpose in trying to put on a
mask and pretend to be this perfect ideal version of myself for what a
man expects a woman should be what hours it is almost
3:00 AM.
17.
Uh, I don't know.
Okay. If you believe hard enough, you can walk on water.
And me being like a 10 year old kid, I was like, that's dope.
I can walk on water if I just believe in Jesus.
But when I was a kid, that story free to meet them.
When you're a kid, you're going to set the scary stories.
Our 21, our 21.
What are your bad habits?
Staying up 24 hours going out
virtually for 24 hours. Great.
The only cereal I will eat is reason for him. I refuse to eat any other cereal.
Cereal. Okay.
Jordan.
So bundled up now. It's cute. But also like falling asleep.
Star Wars, Harry Potter, Harry Potter,
Potter, Harry Potter, Harry Potter.
I don't know anything about Harry Potter. You fool.
Take one. I am
exhausted. I don't recall anything. We talked about this past week.
I've had a fun time so far. It's it's felt, I mean, it's been exactly a day,
but it's felt more than a day.
It's felt like we've gone through multiple phases of ourselves.
Random tired. I'm on Palm sewed hired.
Uh, Jordan, Jordan, you there?
Good morning.
So how was, how was your night.
Super tiring for the last two hours a week or the last three hours?
We were both so exhausted. We weren't even really talking.
We were just kind of like rambling.
Is there any sparks on your end?
The more I talked to him Memorial, like, and like,
I like it now and he seems really chill and he's very, I don't know.
It was really nice.
He was a delight to hang out with.
I don't think that this is going to necessarily blossom
into anything like a relationship. Yeah.
That it's been pretty much a full 24 hours. How do you,
how do you feel, do you feel differently? Do you feel the same?
Yeah. I mean, I feel like my first impression has stayed pretty consistent.
I like her a lot. Really cool. Really cute,
awesome general all around favorites.
I think we have a lot of good similarities,
but also as we were saying, I think,
I think we have like the differences as well. Um,
and I think both are important.
So if I were to offer you guys a second date,
everything paid for both parties have to go in knowing and agree that this is
kind of a romantic second date. Would you take that?
Yeah, a hundred percent. I'd definitely like to go on a second day with her.
What'd you go on a second date?
Romantic. You can be straight up. There's nothing wrong with him.
Like, I'm just like, I don't he's so Simpy like, I don't know.
Hey, what's wrong with that? What if, what if he treats you? Well, you know,
it's just.
Not my type. Like okay.
If I'm hearing you correctly, is that a no.
You have to be romantic in a casual sense. Okay. Okay.
So Jordan, here's my pitch. I'd like, do you want a second day with you?
I'd like to go somewhere where we can meet in person.
So I was thinking we could get COVID tests. We could go, uh,
after that go on a hike or nature somewhere Angeles forest,
watch the sunset or whatever. Just sent out.
I about that. I go on a.
Date with me and can we do a social distance?
Sure. Yeah. Okay, cool. Yeah.
Is it weird asking somebody on a date in front of other people?
Very weird.
Chemistry is that chemical and emotional interaction that two people have and
it's just there. You can't really pinpoint it. And when you feel it, you know,
it's genuine juicing a little bit more consistent Jordan. On the other hand,
I don't know if she was really feeling him romantically. Might not to say that.
Sorry. Will they go on a second date? Was there chemistry there?
Who knows? So next time we'll see you. Thank you for tuning into love floods.
I'm just so uncomfortable. I'm through this right now.
I am fully closed. Thanks.
Ma'am we're on our second date here as I pitched to beach
Rainbird and I'm about to jump in the water, which is why I'm sharing this.